[Music]
hey Vsauce Michael here on July 1st of
2015 a long-standing ban was lifted
visitors were finally allowed to take
selfies at the White House
this is the first legal selfie ever
taken on a White House Tour
but
a year before the ban was lifted in
February of 2014 I met with the
president
and secretly took an illegal selfie
while on the toilet In The West Wing
thanks Obama
why am I admitting to this crime now
well it's time for the truth
who took the first selfie
really
few people would call this a selfie but
it is the oldest known self-portrait a
depiction someone made of themself that
includes Head and Shoulders it was
sculpted more than three thousand years
ago by Pharaoh akhenaten's first Chief
Royal sculptor A guy named Beck next to
himself Beck sculpted his wife to Heart
making this also a contender for oldest
known asy
but the roots of the selfie go back
further than this we have been making
things that resemble ourselves in whole
or in part intentionally or not for as
long as there's been cause and effect
just looking into a pool of water
creates a kind of selfie A Primitive
ephemeral one that you can't preserve or
send to anyone but it is undeniably an
image of the self made by the self even
the earliest life forms on Earth were
capable to some degree of
self-discrimination they could
differentiate themselves from the
environment around them they have inside
them in some chemical form a crude
pre-conscious sense of themselves I call
things like that a first wave selfie
first wave selfies are unintentional
automatic or accidental resemblances
something makes of itself in whole or in
part like prehistoric human Footprints
or the mental images animals have of
their own bodies
the first big leap in selfie history the
second wave began with the first
intentional depictions of oneself second
wave selfies include everything from
Chauvet caves 32 000 year old hand
stencil prints to the paintings of Jan
Von Ike and Judith leister
but in the 19th century self-depiction
changed in another Major Way a
technology emerged that allowed
likenesses of the self to be made faster
and with less skill that seemed more
accurate less mediated and more
indexical than ever before
photography ushered in the third wave
selfie
in the fall of 1839 outside his family's
lamp and chandelier store in
Philadelphia thirty-year-old Robert
Cornelius stood completely still for
about 15 minutes in front of a camera he
built using a modified opera glass and a
sheet of silver plated copper the result
was a significant image it could be
found on his gravestone in
Philadelphia's Laurel Hill Cemetery the
Smithsonian calls it the first selfie
but they also don't in that same fall of
1839 a man named Henry Fitz Jr took a
photograph of himself in Baltimore
Smithsonian Magazine and pretty much
everyone else has called cornelius's
Selfie the first
but in their archives the Smithsonian
calls Fitz Juniors the first the reason
for this confusion is that honestly we
don't know which of these came first all
we can be sure of is that neither of
them is the first equally by r a
Frenchman wrote of taking a photo of
himself in 1837 two years before these
but it's been lost and other even
earlier examples may have been lost as
well because these are photographs
people took of themselves it's largely
uncontroversial to call them selfies but
you know they're not like
selfie selfies if you've seen my video
is cereal soup you know what I just did
there contrastive Focus reduplication
that's when you repeat a word in order
to focus on prototypical examples in
contrast to edge cases for example we
went on a date last night but you know
it wasn't a date date in that statement
I'm contrasting what I did last night
which might have been a date to a true
date date which is obviously a date okay
anyway the point is no one called these
selfies when they were taken they were
photographic self-portraits the word
selfie wouldn't even exist for another
160 years after they were taken so at
some point between this and this our
relationship to self-depiction changed
and our vocabulary had to expand to
discuss it
what rough Beast emerged to make the
coining of selfie necessary
well let's keep going
around 1846 Czech photographer MV
lobethal took the earliest known selfie
with a mirror this of course would
become a classic selfie technique
mirrors provided an easy early way to
capture the self with a camera but in my
opinion this mirror selfie from around
1900 is the most arresting I think you
die at least three times once when your
body stops living again usually sometime
later when your name is spoken for the
last time but now thanks to photography
more and more of us are able to save
ourselves from the third the last time
and image of you is seen the identity of
this woman is unknown that makes it the
oldest known selfie taken by a person
whose name we have forgotten this is the
oldest known example of the classic
outstretched arm selfie technique it was
taken by Joseph Byron in 1909 images
like these were a significant step
toward the eventual fourth wave selfie
the presence of a camera or arms or
poles in the shot evidence of how it was
made are Hallmarks of the modern day
selfie stereotype for example a 2013 ad
campaign for the cape times reimagined
famous historical photographs as selfies
and in every single one an arm
connecting the subject to the camera was
used
five years after Byron's armed selfie
Anastasia nikolivino Romanova the
youngest daughter of Tsar Nicholas II
and great-granddaughter to Britain's
queen Victoria and Prince Albert took
this photo of herself
she was 13 years old at the time so many
have claimed it to be the first selfie
ever taken by a teenager but that's not
true in 1852 61 years earlier British
chemist William Henry Perkin took this
photo of himself when he was just 14.
however even though Anastasia wasn't the
first teenager to take a selfie in
another way she was unlike Perkins whose
shot feels like a self-portrait she took
pictures that feel much more like we
today would call selfies the photos she
took were personal
she sent them to friends to share her
mood and daily life here she is posing
with fake novelty teeth in 1915 or 16.
four years after taking this famous
selfie her camera was confiscated and
not long after Bolshevik revolutionaries
executed her and her entire family
together in a basement conclusive
evidence of her death in 1918 wasn't
uncovered until 2007.
although her work was cut short she
pioneered the use of Photography as a
social behavior as a way to communicate
not just commemorate she has been called
the Kardashian of her day but despite
her influence she was more of a
trendsetter for hairstyles than
photography she didn't usher in a
worldwide shift in Behavior where young
people everywhere started taking selfies
camera manufacturers didn't rush to make
self-portraiture easier and articles
weren't written about how great or how
scary it was that young people were
taking pictures of themselves
though the modern day selfie still
wasn't born it continued to gestate and
kick within the womb one such kick was
the use of sticks and pulls to activate
a camera's shutter in 1925 newlyweds
Arnold and Helen Hogg used a long Pole
to take this picture in 1934 Helmer
Larson used a fallen tree branch to snap
this selfie with his wife naime in
Sweden on Reddit Chooch 37 shared his
grandfather using a selfie stick in the
late 1940s here's one from 1957 and
going back to 1920 here's Joseph Byron
taking a handheld photograph with others
I mentioned this image because a second
camera captured how it was taken giving
us an early depiction of what is now the
recognizable human selfie pose now what
I think makes this image so significant
is that it's another early Taste of the
selfie as we know it today as Jin's
rushitz pointed out in exploring the
selfie if you Google self-portrait you
get a lot of self-portraits there's only
one image that shows someone making a
self-portrait Norman Rockwell's famous
triple self-portrait but if you Google
selfie a lot of what you get aren't
selfies they're pictures of people
taking selfies
four the selfie as we know it today the
pose of taking one is just as if not
more Salient than the actual result
blogs and articles containing outrage
over people taking selfies in
inappropriate places or when they should
be behaving differently rarely complain
about the actual images they dislike the
performance
in 2015 Joanne paternapatania published
a book of pictures of people taking
selfies from which she had removed the
environment giving us what feel like
selfie poses preserved in specimen jars
the idea that those taking photos can be
a nuisance didn't begin with selfies far
from it there's a long tradition of
photographers especially tourists
raising eyebrows for being annoying
centering themselves over the location
and being predictably heard like for
example the Pisa pushers found in Italy
the modern day selfie that was to come
however makes a person look like a
tourist everywhere they go not because
everything suddenly became a landmark
but because people have always loved
looking at themselves and as cameras
became smaller and easier to handle it
was inevitable that people would start
snapping more self-portraits Vivian
Dorothy Meyer took really cool mirror
selfies in the 1950s and 60s but she
kept them to herself her selfies were
unknown and unpublished during her
lifetime a couple of years before her
death she failed to make payments on a
storage unit she rented and her Works
were auctioned off six months after her
death in 2009 a collector who had
acquired them uploaded her images to
Flickr and they went viral inspiring
exhibitions a documentary a road in
Paris was even named after her the
popularization of instant cameras in the
60s and 70s made taking selfies
physically and mentally easier you
didn't need to know how to develop the
film yourself or feel self-conscious
turning in selfies to be developed
but instant cameras with mirrors on the
front didn't come around until decades
later selfies still hadn't reached a
Tipping Point
in 1969 Michael Collins took the first
reverse selfie a photograph that
contains everyone but yourself
Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin are in
this Lander right here and every human
living or dead at that time is on this
ball of Rock Only Collins himself behind
the lens is absent in 1983 Hiroshi wada
submitted a patent for a telescopic
extender for supporting a compact camera
an early selfie stick and two years
prior Lester wisbrod started what was to
become a personal tradition using his
new auto focusing compact camera to snap
selfies with famous people whiz broad
was the pioneer of the celebrity selfie
still though no one was using the word
selfie selfies hadn't become a thing yet
but then
something happened in Japan
in 1995 19 year old toshikawa haromi
known as hero mix was nominated for the
new Cosmos of Photography award by world
renowned photographer Nobi Yoshi araki
she submitted a portfolio of snapshots
she'd taken of her daily life and she
won the grand prize there was already a
unique culture of photo diary and photo
booth use among young people in Japan
but hero mix's sudden Fame amongst
teenagers and the educated Elite made
the practice a thing suddenly young
people all over Japan wanted to be like
her the New York Times called it hero
mix syndrome increased demand for
cameras that made self-portraiture and
proto-instagramming easier LED camera
manufacturers to speed up the release of
features that served immediate frequent
photography hero mix took a lot of
photos tens of thousands and her work
generated polarized reactions some
critics adored her While others found it
all baffled now by the time selfies were
called selfies the same debate was
started again but it was a about the
behavior hero mix had brought into focus
more than a decade before you know it's
hard to say who took the first selfie
but in my opinion hero mix took the
first selfie selfie her work hastened
and christened the arrival of the fourth
wave selfie the selfie as we know it
today
now if it hadn't been her it would have
been someone else people love looking at
themselves and it was becoming easier
and easier to do so but hero mix
popularized taking pictures of yourself
as a social sharing activity more akin
to speaking than remembering less a
memory than a message nowhere is this
more clear than in the story of the
first camera phone picture on June 11
1997 while his wife was in labor
Philippe Khan Jerry rigged together a
makeshift system involving his star
attack flip phone a Casio QV and a
Toshiba laptop when his daughter was
born he took a photo with the camera and
used the laptop and phone connection to
immediately email the image to more than
2 000 people social media is strongly
associated with the fourth wave selfie
but as we've seen it wasn't its origin
instead social media was simply a mouth
that showed up later and demanded to be
fed them
online we have no bodies we can't just
walk in and be seen we have to upload
images of our bodies for them to be
there selfies are an easy solution
because they don't require other
people's help
but on top of that there's a sense in
which a photo of yourself taken by
someone else is that person's point of
view it's their story
but a selfie well a selfie's point of
view doesn't belong to another person
when I look at a selfie of you I'm not a
third Observer looking at you through
someone else's eyes
it's just me
looking at you
selfies allow us to be online first hand
not second hand
in the same way that brown bears who
migrated to the cold lands of the north
evolved pale guard hairs and became
polar bears as humans migrated into the
cold lands of the screen they evolved
selfies
by 2006 everyone knew that something was
happening the New York Times published
an article that year about how young
people were suddenly taking a lot of
photos of themselves
was it weird what did it mean not once
in the article is the word selfie used
but it could have been because sometime
between 1995 and 2006 the word selfie
was born selfie with a Y had been a word
since the 1600s it meant self-centered
or selfish but selfie with an ie is new
the earliest recorded usage of it is
from a September 13 2002 post on Dr
Carl's self-serve science Forum
Australian Nathan hope uploaded an image
he took of how busted up his lip had
gotten and he wrote sorry about the
focus it was a selfie
hope has been hailed as the inventor of
the word selfie but says himself that he
probably heard it somewhere else first
which is likely the word selfie is a
hypocrism a pet name an affectionate
familiar cuter version of an existing
word Australians are famous for doing
this barbecue Barbie mosquito mozzie
Australian Aussie self-portrait selfie
they don't only use I.E they love o s
and Z too Australian English has given
us probs Rando totes saws preggers and
yes even doggo
Myspace was an early incubator of
thriving selfie colonies but in 2004
when Facebook launched as a serious
social media platform for people at
Elite universities there was a brief
feeling that selfies were falling out of
favor however when the iPhone 4 debuted
with a front-facing camera in 2010 the
selfie was declared officially back
in 2013 usage of the word selfie had
jumped 17
000 percent in the last year and Oxford
dictionaries declared it the word of the
year
everyone knew what a selfie was we
started calling things that existed
before the word selfies as well but that
is an anachronym a word used out of
place
in time
anachronyms can be words that have
lingered around too long like when we
say we're dialing a number on a
smartphone even though actual turning
dials are no longer involved or when we
call this tinfoil although it's actually
the cheaper and more durable aluminum
foil that superseded it anachronyms can
also be words from today like selfie
that barge back into the past like
calling these medieval Church singers
the first boy band nailing down the
definition of a selfie in the modern
sense is tricky of course does a selfie
need to be a photograph if not
why
if so do I need to be holding the camera
does the use of a timer or a drone I'm
not even touching mean that it's not a
selfie or just a different kind of
selfie
are humans a selfie since God made us in
His image because of questions like that
I prefer what I've been doing in this
video just allow a selfie to mean
anything that something has made that
resembles itself or part of itself that
covers a lot of stuff but can be broken
down into four waves first wave selfies
are unintentional the second wave began
with the first deliberate depictions of
oneself the third with photography's
promise of recognizable self-depictions
that were significantly more accessible
the fourth wave is when selfies became a
thing a cultural phenomenon motivated by
a desire not just to have images but to
be images
throughout the 20th century especially
we found ourselves increasingly
surrounded by images news and travels
and products and stories the entire
world outside our head could be seen
like never before
not in person but through images in the
midst of this image world was the human
animal an organism that got to look at
images but wasn't one which was too bad
because to be an image was to be
something well selfies gave us that
power they put it in our own hands
photography allows more of us than ever
before to delay the third death but the
fourth wave selfie flattens the
boundaries of time and space now we can
be anywhere whenever
does my face need to be depicted for it
to be a selfie
well in October of 2013 Kim Kardashian
posted this image on Instagram
within a month belfie had been added to
the Urban Dictionary a belfie is a
selfie of your butt but selfie selfie
belfie guides and histories and even a
belfie stick soon followed
and this all raises a serious question
about Society if a selfie of your butt
is called a belfie shouldn't a selfie of
your face
be called a filthy
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
let me show you something I've been
working on it is a star projector it
puts stars all over your bedroom and who
doesn't love that
me because it's always just the same
stars I could see if I went outside
that's why mine is different it shows
the night sky not from Earth but as seen
on trappist-1e an exoplanet that was one
of the first targets of the new web
telescope because it's very likely to be
friendly to life whether or not anything
lives there we don't know yet but what
we do know is that it is the furthest
known habitable exoplanet from which the
naked human eye could still see our sun
you can turn on this projector and see
us just as others might
alien others
problem is the Curiosity box is a
limited edition thing in the Box this
comes in
already sold out
that's why it's important to join now we
are now taking pre-orders for our winter
box and for the holidays it's 50 off I
won't spill too many beans but the
winter box contains something that will
help you if you have no choice
don't miss our best deal of the Year get
your first box for just 30 bucks that's
50 off by using Code Black Friday and
don't forget that Mel science is now
part of our family it's the perfect way
to get your kids thinking and curious
let me put my brain food into your gray
matter mouth
join today